welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today very
sad story yesterday announced a 16 year
old Guatemalan migrant died while in the
custody of Border Patrol at a detention
facility 16 years old so another minor
and this marks the fifth miner to die in
custody of border patrol since December
so six months five deaths all minors so
my question now is where are all those
pro lifers where are all those people
touting the the Alabama abortion ban the
Georgia abortion ban saying that we're
protecting the lives of children we care
so much about children and will do
anything to protect them okay what about
the ones who are literally dropping dead
in these detention facilities along our
southern border where's your concern for
them those are kids who've been alive
living their lives some separated from
their parents and they just died because
of the lack of care the horrid
conditions and the horrid conditions
that they tried to escape there seems to
be no concern among Republicans for
these children and it's because the
Republicans are not actually a pro-life
party they're a pro controlling women
party they don't care about life
whatsoever once a child is born their
concern is over they don't care about
them and I think that's the big point we
always have to hammer when we talk about
these so-called pro lifers because
sending our children sending anyone of
any age off to a war based on lies to
die
that's not pro-life
letting migrant children drop dead in
Border Patrol custody
that's not pro-life starving Medicaid of
money so that poor children in this
country can't get medical care and end
up dying as a result yeah
that's not pro-life either pro-life is
taken care of every single person that
is living and breathing
that's literally pro-life but that is
not what Republicans are and at the same
time that they are ignoring these very
real problems in this country they're
telling us the Democrats are the ones
who hate children
Democrats are the ones who want to kill
children they're the party of death
they're pro-death is what they're
telling us there certainly is a
political party that appears to be Pro
death but I can promise you it isn't the
Democratic Party